foreign
comes from Catherine in Florida she
writes I'm a long time follower of your
baby step program and I enjoy catching
up on your radio show on YouTube that
sentence did not exist a few years ago
my question is about how to deal with
family members opinions on living below
your means driving an older car having
older Electronics a small apartment Etc
I lived in a studio apartment while I
was in college after graduation I landed
a great job working at an investment
advisory firm and moved into a
two-bedroom apartment with a roommate we
both work remotely and use the second
bedroom as an office recently my
roommate's Aunt stopped by to see the
new apartment and commented that it was
small I didn't say anything to her but
inside I felt terrible a two-bedroom
apartment was an upgrade for me in terms
of space and with the increase in my
income and shared expenses I was
spending less money than I was when I
was a student
I know we can't control what others say
and they are definitely entitled to
their opinions I also don't want to
imply that their aunt is judgmental well
she is I just want to know how I can
control that inner voice that felt
embarrassed when someone didn't
understand why I live the way that I do
that's a great question
um I find Dave when I
have not spent some time making sure my
values are anchored into an identity
other people can throw I can I can try
things I can do workout I can do diet
plan or something and somebody will just
casually dismiss it
and all it will affect me but when I
have made a choice I'm a guy who
fill in the blank takes my kid to Waffle
House Waffle House is probably not the
healthiest choice for us but that's
where we go and I love it and I won't
miss it
and so I don't it doesn't even doesn't
even enter my mind when somebody makes a
comment about oh that's not healthy like
because I'm so anchored into that as a
thing or someone dismisses my faith out
of hand like I didn't I don't lose a
second of sleep over that because it's
it's an anchor point to me I've
connected my values with my identity
it it feels like if you're trying
something on
it's a recipe for somebody can speak
into it
you know um but I'm just I'm kind of I'm
kind of thinking off top my head here so
pushback if that doesn't sound right
godliness with contentment
is great game
and so if you are content
and this is your decision
you have peace sitting in the decision
and that's an identity that's a that's a
much less nerdy way to say that I mean I
just you're sitting in your identity
yeah and then you know you're okay if
you know the aunt wants to get a bigger
apartment it's that's her choice but
this is what I wanted and
it's me uh you know you think um
you know I have a black pickup truck you
think black pickup trucks are ugly well
that's okay I'm really comfortable I
picked that truck I like it and so
you know I don't really
give a rip the verbiage for me changed
back when um and you and I've talked
about this quite a bit
when I with the phrase you don't get a
vote yeah and so really sitting down and
deciding being intentional in my life
who are the people who do get a vote
yeah my wife a couple of clothes it's a
very very small list
when it comes to you know I want to
challenge your value yeah I think it
comes down like you said how anchored
are you in this because it's it's a
great discussion that's why we're having
it but the uh
uh
if you're anchored in it and you really
believe
it then you wouldn't be embarrassed yeah
somebody came by and goes uh you know
this guy is green right you're actually
right
when they bring something up
and you're not that anchored in it then
it would throw you off absolutely it's
like I mean do you live in a dump you
know I mean if you do maybe she's
telling you you need to upgrade you know
I mean that that's a that may be what's
going on but if you're just completely
comfortable with that
um
and uh uh
yeah I think that I think you're exactly
right how far you're anchored into it I
mean I got into this thing this morning
I was at a uh another event and I was
one of the speakers and I ended up back
in the green room with a bunch of these
guys that were intellectuals which is
always fun for me because I'm a wiener
in a steakhouse and um so this this guy
is throwing out you know this verbiage
and he's like yes but what about
arbitraging and if you pay off your two
and a half percent mortgage and all this
and I finally looked at him I said dude
I think you need to keep your mortgage
but you asked me
what I thought
and I own several hundred million
dollars worth of real estate debt free
and when covet hit
I wasn't worried about payments so
that's how I live if you don't want to
do it it's okay
but you know even though you're a
bazillion times smarter than me
I got more real estate than you do
I mean you know and it's all paid for so
the real question is can you kick my
my you know
why we are why you know okay I get it
but did you really think you were going
to have a discussion with Dave Ramsey in
the green room and talk him out of into
going into debt and you were going to
sit back and go is there anything I've
never thought of it no way I mean
intellectually that you finally I found
someone who was smart enough that got me
on this no way after 30 years no you're
kidding you know and I'm just like
oh I mean whatever you want to do dude
it's okay I'm not mad at you I love you
you can go you can go get in debt if you
want but as for me and my house we're
pretty anchored in this one pretty much
an identity thing yes I would go back to
Catherine and say why why are you
choosing this life yeah well I want to
live below my my means and okay great
then other people don't get a vote
everything that she said was joyful
absolutely until the aunt showed up and
I'm gonna vote yeah and so she doesn't
get a vote that's all it is it's um and
that's something you practice that's
easier said than done it is and the
other thing is this it's a perspective
thing
um it goes with contentment so the thing
I always remember is this I have the
inordinate benefit of having gone
completely broke and once you've gone
completely broke you really don't care
what other people think
because you figure out most of them
aren't going to be around anyway it's
like watching a fighter that's been
knocked out they're a little Wilder the
next time because they oh that's what
happens oh that's how it works I didn't
I didn't die from it now I'm gonna I'm
gonna lean in here and you know I love
folk and I I want you to win and I want
to help you but
um I'm not really taking a poll
you know before I make a decision on
stuff I'm not I'm just I lost what the
Bible calls fear of man I just don't
I don't need affirmation to make good
quality value-based decisions I make
those decisions regardless and if I get
some affirmation that's wonderful I'm
like anybody else I like it but I don't
have to have that to do anything and
honestly when some of you get pissed off
it kind of inspires me so
um you know I it causes me to go to
double down you know so
um and because I found that most of you
are that wrong and so that's why we do
this show for 30 years is to help you
you know and so yeah I think there's a
lot of that going on in the contentment
thing is contentment is do I have peace
am I anchored in this with a deep a part
of my identity
um and how much affirmation do I need to
support my values based decisions and uh
the less of that you need the better
financial decisions you're going to make
all day every day because most people
are broke and if your broke friends are
making fun of your financial plan you
are right on track well and the better
parenting decisions you'll make I don't
want my kid to be the only kid with
three-year-old without their own iPad be
the only one I don't want my kid to be
the only you're gonna make better
parenting better marriage decisions you
make every every decision will be better
when you identify who gets a vote and
who doesn't and when you identify that
identity and what it's anchored into man